It could be argued that flying was in Pancho’s
blood.
Born into a wealthy family in 1901, Florence
Leontine Lowe, as she was originally known,
grew up in a large mansion in California.
Her family’s wealth was built on aviation.
Pancho’s grandfather was Thaddeus S.C. Lowe,
the man responsible for establishing the United
States’ first military air unit during the
Civil War.
The Union Army Baloon Corps might have been
made up of hot air balloons rather than airplanes,
but it was fairly revolutionary in its time.
It was also Grandpa Lowe who took Pancho to
her first air show when she was ten years
old, cementing her love of flight at a young
age.
Despite being born into wealth, Pancho resisted
the expectations of rich society from a young
age.
Her father was an avid outdoorsman who allowed
Pancho to join him in sport while her mother
was busy caring for a sick uncle.
She was treated like a son rather than a daughter,
and she liked it that way.
She was given a Thoroughbred horse for her
fifth birthday and won her first equestrian
trophy later that same year.
Not only was she a tomboy at home, but after
a brief stint of home schooling, she was sent
to Padadena Elementary School where she was
the only girl in a classroom with twenty-three
boys.
Not much is known about the quality of education
she received in the usual subjects, but she
did learn to run fast, spit, curse, and fight
better than her peers.
When they learned of her behaviour, her parents
eventually moved her to a Catholic boarding
school.
Barnes promptly ran away to Tijuana on horseback
after two years.
When she eventually graduated from an Episcopalian
boarding school, Pancho announced to her parents
that she wanted to be a veterinarian.
At the time, this was an unheard of profession
for women and a particularly appalling idea
to her well-to-do mother, who encouraged her
daughter to pursue a more lady-like profession.
Though she resisted becoming a lady, a marriage
between Pancho and an Episcopalian reverend
was arranged.
Pancho looked at it as a shot at independence
rather than being tied down—at least she
could break free from her demanding mother!
Thus, Pancho married Reverend C. Rankin Barnes
in 1921 and they had a child together nine
months later.
Needless to say, Pancho was bored stiff being
a preacher’s wife.
She took a shot at teaching Sunday school,
but it didn’t quite live up to her childhood
adventures on horseback.
Luckily, she had some success in Hollywood,
where she was hired to ride horses in movies.
She was such a good rider that she could even
carry a camera on her shoulder while on horseback,
making around $100 every day doing just that.
(About $1000 today.)
The money went straight into hiring a cook,
nanny, and housekeeper—with the servants
effectively taking over Pancho’s duties
as a housewife and mother.
When Pancho’s mother died when she was just
twenty-two years old, her father remarried
a woman just a few years older than Pancho
was.
In a fit of anger, Pancho ran off and started
a series of affairs with men who weren’t
boring, upstanding Episcopalian preachers
as a kind of revenge.
Her family soon caught wind of her shenanigans.
Pressured to leave due to the family’s embarrassment,
she signed up to crew a banana boat headed
for South America with some of her friends.
Dressing as a man and taking on the name Jacob
Crane, Pancho set sail for Mexico.
She and the crew soon discovered that they
were running weapons and ammunition to revolutionaries
there.
When they landed, not everything went as planned.
The ship was boarded by Mexican guards who
held the crew hostage for six weeks.
Only Pancho and one other crew member had
the courage to escape from their captors.
The two escapees stole a horse and started
their journey back to the States.
It was during this stint that Pancho earned
her nickname.
She said that her partner looked a bit like
Don Quixote, and he said that that made her
“Pancho,” mistaking the name of the character
“Sancho.”
Even with the mistake, Pancho decided she
quite liked the sound of “Pancho Barnes”
and the name stuck with her until her death.
After returning to California, Pancho sought
her next great adventure.
In 1928, she began taking flying lessons and
took her first solo flight after just six
hours of instruction.
She went on to become one of the first female
pilots to earn her license in the United States,
and in 1930 she beat Amelia Earhart’s speed
record.
Buying herself a $5,500 plane, she decided
to turn her hobby into an enterprise, earning
money from being a test pilot and doing promotional
flights.
Later, she also became a stunt pilot, returning
to Hollywood to feature in movies again—this
time in a metal bird rather than on a horse.
Unfortunately, Pancho lived a lavish lifestyle.
She wasn’t used to saving money and tended
to spend it on parties for her friends and
additional real estate that she wouldn’t
use.
By 1935, she ran out of funds and moved to
a small house on an alfalfa farm in the middle
of nowhere, where she stayed with her horses
and airplane.
Her son, Billy, helped out on the farm every
now and then—he had been living with his
dad while his mother went adventuring, but
enjoyed the freedom of the farm.
Pancho was also visited by flyboys and her
Hollywood friends, which unfortunately didn’t
do her pocketbook much good.
During this time, she continued to host a
string of lovers as well.
In 1939, her first husband asked for a divorce
that had been a long time coming.
She then married Robert Hudson Nichols, Jr.
shortly after the divorce, but the union lasted
just two weeks.
In 1944, she was visited by a show dancer
named Don Shalita, who she married and lived
with for a whole four months.
She remarried in 1952 for a fourth time to
Mac McKendry.
The reception was a lavish affair, with a
50-pound wedding cake, 16 gallons of Jell-O,
and the one and only Lassie as entertainment.
When Pancho received an inheritance upon her
uncle’s death, she started enhancing her
property.
She put in runways and encouraged pilots to
fly in and tie up their planes for free, as
long as they purchased oil and gas from her.
She also converted the guest house, adding
more private bathrooms.
Her property even boasted a repair shop and
a flight school.
She called it a “modern flying dude ranch”
and advertised for families to join her for
just $49 per week.
But Pancho wasn’t one to miss out on the
old days—she also created a private club
called “The Happy Bottom Riding Club”
exclusively for her pilot and Hollywood buddies,
where they could drink and tell stories.
Illegal liquor was flown in from Mexico and
“hostesses” waited the tables and danced
with the guests.
The pilots’ wives seemed to think that those
women did more than “hostess” but Pancho
denied the claims.
Pancho was at the height of her happiness
then, but it wouldn’t last.
In 1952, the government started buying up
the land around the Edwards Air Force Base
to build a long runway, and that meant Pancho’s
beloved Happy Bottom Riding Club was on the
chopping block.
After a series of law suits, the government
finally won the title to Pancho’s property,
and she was given $185,000 ($1.5 million today)
as recompense.
She tried to start over, but Happy Bottom
had taken her twenty long years to build.
Pancho still had trouble managing her money
which wasn’t good for business.
She was also diagnosed with breast cancer
and underwent a double mastectomy.
As if that wasn’t enough, her relationship
with her fourth husband crumbled soon after,
and while it was the longest relationship
she’d maintained—lasting almost ten years—she
filed for divorce in 1962.
She did end up leaving Mac McKendry her worldly
possessions in her will, though, so she must
have liked him better than her previous husbands.
Pancho wasn’t able to get back on her feet.
She died in 1975 in less-than-glamorous surrounds;
it’s thought that breast cancer was the
ultimate cause of death.
Her ashes were scattered over her old ranch.
Despite falling from grace toward the end
of her life, Pancho was always upbeat.
As she liked to say, “When you have a choice,
choose happy!”
As to perhaps being somewhat overlooked as
a pioneering female aviator over the much
more widely publicized Amelia Earhart and
Harriet Quimby, among others- largely due
to Poncho’s “unladylike” exploits and
penchant for off-color quotes like, “Flying
makes me feel like a sex maniac in a whorehouse
with a stack of $20 bills”- her response
to such observations was, “Hell, [I] had
more fun in a week than those weenies had
in
a lifetime!”